[Música]
quisiera compartirles una historia de
una persona a la que llamaremos a na
anna es una mujer se considera a sí
misma saludable
tiene 32 años no fuma
no toma alcohol nunca usado drogas
sin embargo ella desde los 18 años de
edad
empezó sin motivo aparente a
experimentar sentimientos de vacío una
profunda tristeza que no identificaba en
la causa
perdió la capacidad para disfrutar cosas
que ella normalmente disfrutaba hacer
como convivir con su familia
tener su pareja escuchar música salir a
pasear
fueron tan notables estos cambios en su
conducta y en su modo de vida que su
propia familia se preguntó se preocupó
por ella y empezó a buscar alguna
explicación para entender qué era lo que
le estaba pasando
acudieron con un médico y el médico les
dio el diagnóstico de trastorno
depresivo mayor
ella ya tiene 14 años con este
diagnóstico ha pasado por un sinnúmero
de tratamientos
y no ha logrado un adecuado control de
estos síntomas ha tenido cuatro intentos
de quitarse la vida ante la frustración
de no poder controlar esa tristeza de no
poder controlar esos sentimientos
negativos que a veces la hago bien y fue
precisamente después de este último
intento que acude conmigo
cuando acude pues hacemos un protocolo
para identificar alguna otra causa que
pudiera estar generando estos estos
síntomas y descartar enfermedades
médicas realizamos ajustes en los
tratamientos que ya tenía agregamos
otros medicamentos
y no obteníamos los resultados que
estábamos esperando
ella se sentía tan frustrada como yo y
me empezaba a externar que volvía a
considerar la idea de quitarse la vida
ante esta desesperación y ante esta
ansiedad que le generaba el pensar que
siempre iba a vivir sufriendo con este
padecimiento
fue entonces cuando yo como último
alternativa que tenía a la mano le
propuse el iniciar una terapia
experimental
con un medicamento que todavía no se
encuentra aprobado para el tratamiento
de estos síntomas pero ha presentado
resultados prometedores tanto en estados
unidos como a nivel mundial
para darnos un poquito de contexto les
voy a dar algunas cifras sobre la
depresión
en el mundo existen actualmente más de
300 millones de personas que padecen
depresión
esto ha vuelto a la depresión la
principal causa de discapacidad en el
mundo y con el suicidio como su
principal complicación es la segunda
causa de muerte para las personas entre
15 y 29 años
en méxico según datos del inegi se
suicidan al año más de 6000 personas y
estas cifras han ido en aumento al punto
de que las predicciones nos dicen que
para el año 2020 va a ser la principal
causa de muerte a nivel mundial el
suicidio asociado a trastornos del
estado de ánimo
estos datos son alarmantes y si a esto
le adjudicamos le agregamos el hecho de
que
incluso las personas que sí responden a
un tratamiento antidepresivo un tercio
de ellas va a presentar una recaída o
dos recaídas a lo largo de su vida
y que un tercio de las personas que
reciban un tratamiento para la depresión
no va a responder hasta después de
utilizar tres o más medicamentos vuelven
los pronósticos para la depresión como
más sombríos
cómo podemos entender la depresión la
depresión es una enfermedad mental
es una enfermedad tienen un fundamento
físico de la manera en la que trabaja el
cerebro
y se da por un conjunto de factores
vienen desde factores individuales que
serían cambios en la estructura la
química cerebral dadas por consumo de
sustancias por antecedentes de trauma
por infecciones por tumores factores
genéticos una persona que tiene padres
que han padecido depresión tiene tres
veces más riesgo de padecer la
enfermedad en comparación con otra
persona que tiene padres sanos en
gemelos gemelos idénticos y un gemelo
tiene depresión el otro tiene un 70 por
ciento mayor de probabilidades de
padecer esta enfermedad en comparación
con otro par de gemelos sanos
es de otros factores también se
encuentran factores propios de la
personalidad de una persona una persona
que tiene baja autoestima que no
responde bien ante la frustración
también tiene un mayor riesgo de padecer
la enfermedad el medio ambiente en el
que nos volvemos a vivir en ambientes
tóxicos de estar expuestos a violencia
física violencia psicológica
el estar bajo mucho estrés problemas
familiares laborales sociales
todos estos factores convergen y en
personas susceptibles hacen que detone o
que aparezcan los síntomas de la los
síntomas de la enfermedad
qué es lo que pasa ya que tenemos la
enfermedad bueno nuestro cerebro empieza
a presentar una serie de cambios
químicos en los cuales algunas
sustancias disminuyen su actividad
otras aumentan estas sustancias son
conocidas como neurotransmisores son
encargados de la comunicación entre las
diferentes estructuras del cerebro y del
propio cerebro con el resto del
organismo y esta disfunción es la que
genera los síntomas que todos conocemos
con escuchamos la palabra depresión la
tristeza las ideas de que no valemos la
falta de energía la falta de motivación
etcétera
una persona deprimida les digo presenta
todos estos sentimientos negativos
no es una cuestión de actitud no es una
cuestión de que no le eche ganas
físicamente está incapacitado para poder
ver las cosas de la manera que a
nosotros nos gustaría que ellos la
vieran su momento
y es lo que les quiero explicar un poco
les quiero hablar del fundamento
científico de que nos explica por qué la
persona no puede salir nada más con
actitud que existe una región que se
acaba de identificar recientemente en el
cerebro
que suprime lo que llamaríamos nosotros
como el centro del placer existe una
parte de nuestro cerebro un circuito una
serie de regiones que se conectan entre
sí que se le llama el sistema de
recompensa este sistema evolutivamente
nos habla nos ha ayudado a que nosotros
formemos hábitos o tengamos ciertas
conductas y nuestro cerebro nos premia
de cierta manera brindamos una sensación
de bienestar para hacer ejercicio el
comer el dormir rico todo eso nos da
cierto placer y es esta región que nos
está estimulando para que lo hagamos
nuestro serio dice que está bien y que
deberíamos de seguirlo haciendo
existe una región que tiene que
compensar esta función entonces se ha
identificado esta región como la ave
nula lateral
podremos llamar el sistema de anti
recompensa que lo que hace es suprimir a
ese sistema para que para las conductas
contrarias
entonces los estudios recientes han
identificado que en la depresión este
sistema de anti recompensa se cuenta
sobre activado o hiper activado que es
lo que hace nos bloquea completamente
esta capacidad para disfrutar para
sentir placer para encontrarnos
motivados para tener energía
los síntomas que ya veníamos comentando
de igual manera estudios recientes nos
han picado
que hay sustancias que actúan
específicamente en este sistema de anti
recompensa bloqueando su señal evitando
que frene al sistema de recompensa
estas sustancias que se han identificado
recientemente comparten una
característica son drogas psicoactivas
qué quiere decir esto son drogas que
producen alucinaciones que nos producen
este efecto psicodélico como la
psilocibina que es la sustancia que se
encuentra los hongos alucinógenos llc de
drogas como la ketamina que es la que
estoy edita y tomando como principal
elemento para esta charla
la que también es un anestésico se
utiliza tanto en veterinaria como en la
medicina en general
este anestésico tiene la propiedad de
que bloquea a los 30 minutos de haberle
administrado bloquea completamente en la
actividad de esta región
y este bloqueo se mantiene hasta por dos
semanas después de haberlo administrado
lo que nos da una remisión de los
síntomas de una persona deprimida de
manera sorprendente estamos hablando de
que la media hora de que yo le aplique
el medicamento ella ya va a tener una
actitud completamente diferente
y eso fue precisamente lo que yo le
propuse anna después de haber agotado
las posibilidades que teníamos a la mano
le comenté de los riesgos potenciales
que podría tener y los beneficios que yo
esperaba que obtuviera con este
tratamiento con esta información ella
aceptó llevar a cabo el ensayo clínico y
lo primero que hicimos fue agregarle una
escala le hice una serie de preguntas un
cuestionario en el cual yo evaluaba los
síntomas de la depresión para poder ver
qué tan severos eran en ella antes de
iniciar el tratamiento la puntuación que
me dio pena compatibles con una
depresión muy severa
administramos el tratamiento y a los
días siguientes de aplique nuevamente la
escala
los resultados que ella presentó en la
segunda toma de la muestra eran
compatibles con una depresión leve
anda tiene ya cuatro meses de que le
iniciamos la terapia está siendo tratada
con una dosis mínima de antidepresivos y
los síntomas de la depresión no han
vuelto
y está motivada y feliz sus palabras en
mucho tiempo ella tiene una nueva
perspectiva sobre la vida y sobre todo
ya no ve la depresión como una sentencia
de muerte para ella
el uso de estas sustancias plantea
dilemas éticos y morales yo no estoy
diciendo que es la solución para todos
los casos hay situaciones en las que no
se puede llegar a administrar gente que
tiene un potencial de abuso a fin de
cuentas tiene efectos psicoactivos y
puede ser abusada como droga pues no se
le puede administrar gente que tiene
antecedentes de cuadros psicóticos por
los mismos efectos psicodélicos que
puede llegar a presentar no se les puede
administrar
pero esta esta otra parte de las
personas que no tienen estos dos
criterios podríamos decirle que se
pueden ver potencialmente beneficiados
con este tipo de tratamiento
en este caso particular de la que
también en las dosis que se utilizan son
mucho menores a las que se utilizan en
anestesia general cualquier riesgo o
efecto secundario que pudiera tener el
abuso de la sustancia se neutraliza
prácticamente por las dosis tan bajas y
el beneficio lo supera por mucho el
pequeño riesgo que pudiera llegar a
conllevar
en eeuu no se encuentra probada todavía
por la fe sin embargo como les repito
por ser un medicamento si se pueden
realizar ensayos clínicos y proyectos de
investigación y gracias a eso muchas
universidades y clínicas han estado
llevando muchos estudios alrededor del
mundo comprobando esta terapia
comprobando esta eficacia y tratando de
identificar la partícula o la sustancia
específica libre del componente
psicoactivo adictivo que nos puede
ocasionar esos síntomas para que para
desarrollar medicamentos mejores y más
específicos que se puedan utilizar con
mucha más libertad con mucha más
tranquilidad
sabemos que a nivel mundial ahorita el
dilema de la legalización de las drogas
está en boca de todos
y no estoy hablando sobre legalizar o
sobre hablar de dejar de satanizar el
uso de las sustancias a lo que yo me
refiero es que inclusive la marihuana lo
que les había comentado llc de drogas
psicoactivas se ha comprobado que tiene
un efecto benéfico para enfermedades muy
particulares de difícil control y que
muchas veces es la mejor alternativa o
la única alternativa que se puede llegar
a utilizar se deberían de crear mejores
políticas públicas se debería de
legislar a favor de la experimentación y
la investigación con estas sustancias
para poder identificar las partículas
libres del efecto adictivo que nos da en
este efecto que nosotros estamos
encontrando tan sorprendentemente
benéfico en las personas
esta charla trae en mi mente el llamado
principio de paracelso
para celso fue un médico y alquimista
que fue muy famoso poco conocido como el
padre de la toxicología debido a sus
experimentaciones con sustancias venenos
cosas que la gente consideraba tóxicas
el trabajaba bajo una premisa que
parafraseada más o menos decía la dosis
hacia el veneno
qué quiere decir esto cualquier
sustancia
inclusive el agua puede llegar a ser
nociva para nosotros voy a llegar a ser
letal para nosotros en las dosis
adecuadas y de igual manera existen
venenos hemos visto sobre venenos de
alacrán veneno de viuda negra' existen
metales como el litio existen drogas
como la ketamina los hongos alucinógenos
llc de
que han probado que en las dosis
adecuadas
son eficaces para tratar problemas que
parece que no hay otra solución que no
hay otra alternativa tan importante o
tan efectiva como ellas
entonces mi intención con esta plática
comentarles el caso de anna es de que
tengamos un panorama más completo acerca
de cómo estas enfermedades tienen un
efecto tan devastador y un crecimiento
casi epidémico todos conocemos a alguien
que tiene depresión o que ha tenido
depresión o que tendrá depresión
imagínense nosotros los médicos
cuando vamos a iniciar nuestra práctica
profesional
tomamos el llamado juramento de
hipócrates
en el juramento de hipócrates nosotros
decimos a grandes rasgos que vamos a
hacer todo lo que esté de nuestra mano
para el bienestar de las personas que
están afligidas
si yo estoy encontrando sustancias si yo
estoy encontrando medicamentos
alternativas que pueden llegar a tratar
una de las enfermedades más devastadoras
del siglo 21 mi pregunta y mi reflexión
que les quiero dejar es por qué no
habríamos de intentarlo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]